okay kids story time oh i love story
time
66 million years ago it was a perfect
day dinosaurs roam the earth
tending to their young feeding enjoying
the warmth of the sun
[Music]
fish and sea creatures weave through
tangled algae in the deep
waters of the ocean tiny mammals
burrowed in holes
deep in the ground snug and safe from
the predators lurking above
and then in one second the world ended
[Music]
let's find out why
welcome to the y-files where smart folks
like us come to laugh and learn
66 million years ago the entire course
of history on our planet changed in an
instant a giant asteroid
almost 20 kilometers wide or about twice
the size of mount everest smashed into
the earth
at 12 miles per second per second that's
over
50 000 kph or 40 times the speed of
sound
what happened well chaos happened chaos
that would cause
mile high tsunamis across entire oceans
and walls of fire across entire
continents
chaos that would wipe out 70 percent of
life on earth chaos that would kill the
dinosaurs and chaos that would change
our planet forever
the asteroid smacked into the yucatan
peninsula resulting in a massive
explosion that created one of the
largest known
impact craters on earth at 93 miles in
diameter this happened just outside the
little town of modern-day chick-charlie
mexico this catastrophic event
is known as the chick-shaloob impact
what kind of lube
chick-chalupa got it the estimated
energy of the impact was somewhere
between two
and over 50 yatta joules is a yadda
jules a lot of joules
oh yes let's keep it conservative and
say the impact was
two yatta joules that's the same as 40
billion times
the energy delivered by the atomic bomb
in hiroshima
40 billion times and all of that energy
occurred in less than one second
all at once the cretaceous period which
lasted about 80 million years
ended the very second this asteroid hit
the earth this gave way to a new era
a era of calamitous death and
destruction of massive craters and
flaming forests
of the extinction of the dinosaurs this
moment the moment of the chiksulu impact
marked the beginning
of the cenozoic era the blast was so
extreme
that in the sky above it where there
should have been air the rock had
punched a hole of
outer space vacuum and as the atmosphere
rushed in to close the hole
enormous volumes of earth were expelled
into orbit and beyond
all within a second or two of impact now
this material which included pieces of
the asteroid itself were set aflame
and rained back down on the earth as
fiery rock
each chunk the size of a skyscraper the
impact had other disastrous consequences
a mega tsunami over 330 feet tall
erupted from the sea and stretched all
the way from mexico to texas
in florida and that was lucky lucky yep
the water in the gulf of mexico is
relatively shallow
if the asteroid had struck in the deep
pacific ocean it would have unleashed
tsunamis
five kilometers high that sounds higher
than a mountain
it's higher than most aircraft fly oh
boy is it over yet
oh no it's just getting started across
land for thousands of miles death was
instant and this is shown by fossils
discovered in soil samples from new
jersey
which is 3 100 miles away now while some
life survived the impact
there was an immediate mass extinction
of millions of species as for the
dinosaurs
no one knows whether their species died
out all at once or if it took weeks to
fully eliminate them
but either way this was the day the
dinosaurs died when the asteroid hit
it plunged deep underground less than
one second later
superheated dust ash and steam exploded
from the depths of the crater and were
thrown high into the earth's atmosphere
rocks at the impact site contained large
amounts of sulfur
that when vaporized led to a sulfate
haze that spread across the entire
surface of the earth and led to years of
environmental conditions that would
suffocate
even more life on the planet known as an
impact winter
the dust ash and haze blocked out the
sun
creating a decade-long winter across the
entire planet
winter is here well father always
promised didn't he
plants just couldn't grow in these
conditions and the food chain was
demolished
it was impossible for dinosaurs to
survive if they didn't die immediately
after impact
they were definitely wiped out by the
end of the impact winter
how does winter kill animals we have
winters all the time
at least once a year well this winter
was different
it lasted years and there was no sun it
was darkness
without sun photosynthesis stops without
photosynthesis
plants die without plants animals die
without animals
bigger animals die across the entire
planet food
wasn't just scarce it was gone ugh
did things get better yet no they get
worse
don't cry it out loud particles and
gases released by the many
perhaps thousands of volcanic eruptions
decimated the earth's climate poisonous
snow
fell around the world for years seas
turned acidic air was barely breathable
plants and animals that didn't freeze
suffocated or starved the animals that
died on the day of the impact
were the lucky ones does winter finally
end i mean did they kill the night king
or whatever yeah eventually things get
warmer
ugh happy ending at least sorta
the volcanoes were also releasing carbon
dioxide so once the impact particles had
evaporated from the atmosphere
the co2 remained creating a runaway
greenhouse effect
so the planet began to warm again now
surviving life forms most likely species
that live beneath the surface were
protected from the blast and its
aftermath
by deep dens and they had a chance to
prosper at the end of the winter
cold-blooded reptiles who could not
generate their own body heat had a far
smaller chance of survival this period
of warming led to the creation of new
fertile habitats across the globe and
any life that had survived so far
thrived once again this new version of
the earth looked completely different
from the days of the dinosaurs
predatory birds and reptiles no longer
dominated the food chain
mammals were prospering the version of
the earth that we know today
had finally begun the chikshilu impact
which has been theorized for decades
was only recently discovered in 1978
geophysicists glenn penfield and antonio
carmogo
were working for the mexican oil company
pemex as part of an airborne magnetic
survey of the gulf of mexico
scouting possible locations for oil
drilling their data showed a large
concentric set of onshore gravity
anomalies that looked an awful lot like
an impact crater about the same time
nobel prize-winning geologist luis
alvarez and his son walter were studying
chemicals in the soil when they
discovered large amounts of iridium
dating back to 65 million years no
that's what captain america's shield is
made of no no
that's vibranium iridium is an element
that's rare on earth but it's commonly
found in meteors
superheroes are commonly found in
meteorites okay
okay you're excited about mcu phase four
but let's
let's stay focused sorry sorry sorry go
ahead it was then that luis alvarez
theorized that a massive asteroid
might have hit the earth at the
beginning of the cenozoic era the same
iridium was found in soil
all around the globe and it contained
large amounts of soot which would
indicate forest fires
across the planet during the same time
also grains of quartz were found within
the soil that had been deformed
by high shock waves common during
explosions
now in 1990 scientists finally confirmed
the massive crater now buried under
deep layers of limestone they did this
by drilling and mapping gravity fields
over the gulf of mexico
still there's no complete certainty
about dinosaur extinction nobody knows
if they were killed in an instant
or in a month or over the course of
years most of them probably died during
the impact winter
it's crazy to think that a nice day can
turn catastrophic in an instant
but it can one geophysicist said it
would have been a pleasant day one
second
and the world was already over by the
next now the worst disaster movie
hollywood could ever create
shrek would not even come close to the
destruction
the nightmare the absolute horror that
was unleashed that day
literally out of the blue if there's a
lesson to be learned
it's live today like tomorrow's gonna
suck amen brother
our existence is fragile there are
millions of asteroids in the solar
system and they range in size from small
pebbles up to 600 miles across
much larger than the chick shaloob
asteroid in fact there are almost
2 million asteroids in our solar system
that are one kilometer wide or larger
and many asteroid orbits intersect with
the earth's
meteor showers like the leonids and the
perseids and others
occur when the earth flies through
debris fields in space
so you're saying this could happen again
oh there's no doubt about it
there have been other mass extinctions
that remain mysteries to this day
about 250 million years ago it's
believed that around 90 percent of
species were eliminated during a period
called
the great dying meteors impact the earth
every day and they've been doing so
since the beginning of time
so it's not a question of if another
large impact is going to occur on earth
it's just a question of when nasa tracks
the orbits of thousands of celestial
objects
there's been some pretty close calls
over the years and i don't mean
40 years ago or 60 i mean last july
asteroid 2019 okay missed the earth by
000 miles that's much closer to us than
the moon
and this thing was moving at almost 90
000 kph
now even though it was relatively small
it had the energy of
30 times the atomic blast at hiroshima
it was called a city killer
in august of 2020 an asteroid the size
of a truck
passed only 1800 miles above the indian
ocean
that's closer to us than a lot of
orbiting satellites that's a close shave
it was there are some scientists many
scientists who believe that the greatest
threat to our civilization
is not war or plague or climate change
but another meteor impact now
fortunately we have the technology to
venture to asteroids
and potentially even change their
trajectory if we don't get this job done
everybody's gone but these projects are
expensive
and spectacular impacts are so rare that
there's not a lot of support for this
type of initiative
but there probably should be now if we
could take a break from fighting with
each other for just a minute
and turn our eyes skyward we might see
that every human being every form of
life on this planet has a common enemy
and it's just a matter of time before
that enemy comes knocking
thanks for hanging out with us today my
name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files we covered a
lot today they got me thinking about
potential new videos and let me know in
the comments
if you'd like to learn about how we
visit asteroids the potential for mining
them
and how we can avoid the type of impact
that threatens all life on the planet
we're working hard for you so do us a
favor give us a thumbs up and if we
haven't earned your subscription today i
promise
we'll keep making fun brainy content
until we do earn it until next time be
safe be kind
and know that you are appreciated